hey you guys welcome once again to my
flickers of fear movie review show uh
and just like i mentioned on the last
couple reviews it's the month of
december and i decided that i was going
to do all not necessarily christmas
horror movies because there's not really
enough of those i guess and i've already
reviewed a lot of them but i did
actually want to do
winter themed horror movies at least for
this month i might do it for the whole
winter we'll see where we're uh where
we're at with that but i because i kind
of feel like i really really like
horror movies set in really isolated
wintry locations it just makes it
creepier to me maybe it's because i grew
up in florida and it doesn't snow here
and so it almost seems like an alien
landscape but a little bit i don't know
i don't know what it is but uh so yeah
so i'm gonna try to do that uh all this
month so
to that end the one we are talking about
today
is a 2015 film called the black coats
daughter
now
i reviewed uh i am the pretty thing that
lives in the house a while back which
came out in 2016
and i think i mentioned on there that
was actually uh the second directorial
uh film that uh was done by oz osgood oz
perkins who obviously the son of anthony
perkins uh started out as an actor
and then went into directing now even
though i am the pretty thing
actually premiered on netflix in 2016
first
this movie the black coat's daughter was
actually made before it
um but it didn't get a wide release
until after i am the pretty thing came
out on netflix and there was a little
bit of buzz about it so this is actually
the black coats daughter is actually oz
perkins directorial debut this is his
first movie and uh so it's kind of
confusing how because this movie did
actually premiere in 2015 i think at the
toronto film festival and like fantastic
fest and stuff but then it sort of went
into
limbo with like distribution deals and
whatnot
so it took like a long time to sort of
get a wide release i don't think it ever
got a theatrical release if it did it
was very limited but uh you know it came
out like on streaming platforms later in
2017 i think uh but the movie had been
out like a few years prior to that now
interestingly it started out when it was
first released it was actually released
under the title of february i'm not
entirely sure
i think it might still be called that in
some territories like i think in europe
uh if this is on uk netflix maybe some
uk viewers can tell me i think that it's
still called that uh but in the us and
possibly canada i think it's still
called the black coats daughter and
that's the you know the title that i'm
gonna use
now
this movie
is really really difficult to discuss
without spoiling it so i'm gonna say
that this is one because i kind of
wanted to do a deep dive on it this
movie is this is the second time that
i've watched it
and
this is one of those movies that the
more times you watch it like the more
layers reveal themselves
and again it's very difficult to talk
about without talking talking about like
the twists and spoilers and things like
that so i am going to discuss it uh in
depth so that will necessitate spoilers
that said i think this is a really good
movie where you want to go into it
knowing as little as possible
i normally advocate that for most movies
but this one in particular i think it's
better to go into it not really knowing
where it's going
uh so if you haven't seen the movie and
you want to approach it that way then
probably you shouldn't watch this you
just go watch the movie first and then
come back because i'm going to spoil all
kinds of [ __ ] about it
now i will say though just out front
before i spoil anything that if you
didn't dig
i am the pretty thing that lives in the
house if you didn't dig uh oz perkins
newer movie gretel and hansel then you
will probably not dig this one either
because it's still very it's very
arthouse
um it's very
deliberately paced it's very it's and
and i will say that like i am the pretty
thing which i loved by the way but i can
understand like how some people's like
oh nothing happened or it was like
boring or whatever i get that um i don't
agree but everybody has subjective
tastes you know
um i will say that i am the pretty thing
is actually
a bit more abstract than this one and is
not
because really not a lot happens in that
this one is actually has a lot of the
same aspects of i am the pretty thing
like the way the shots are composed you
know the way the uh the dialogue unfolds
everything's kind of like implication
ambiguity but more stuff does
quote-unquote happen in this uh so in
the third act you do actually get quite
a lot of violence uh you know and some
gore and stuff uh whereas i am the
pretty thing is just more kind of like a
very staid uh ghost story
this one has more of a
a little bit more i don't want to say
over the top but it has a little bit
more of a horror aspect to it i guess um
in the sense that it does have to do
with
you know there are some real violent
sequences and there is some stuff about
demonic kind of [ __ ] going on in it too
like pretty clearly
so i don't know if that like changes
your mind about wanting to watch it or
not because like i said i know that some
people the main criticism of i am the
pretty thing was like oh nothing
happened uh you know it was just kind of
like these creepy shots of empty rooms
and stuff like that but this has a lot
of that to it
where there's long shots of uh you know
just kind of creepy corridors and empty
rooms and like a lot of the
conversations between the characters are
kind of like halting or you're not
ambiguous and you're not really sure
what it all means a lot of stuff is kind
of
left to implication and that's what i
mean when i say you really have to see
this one a couple of times because the
more times you see it like the more
layers kind of reveal themselves i do
kind of feel like a lot of people the
first time they saw this were sort of
confused as to how the two storylines
tied together
i did not find that confusing it was
pretty clear to me like when the twist
or whatever you want to call it was
revealed uh but i can understand why
some people might have been confused by
it but i will say like i said if you if
you dug the movie the first time and you
were just kind of like well i didn't
really quite get it watch it again uh
with the foreknowledge
of what happens at the end and how the
two stories tie together and um i think
you'll find that there's a lot of little
clues and things like that that are kind
of turning up in there
that maybe passed you by the first time
because you didn't know what the ending
was going to be so this movie
essentially uh and this is probably like
where the spoilery stuff starts i'm just
going to give a plot synopsis but then
i'll get into the stuff but um you know
like i said
if you don't want to know anything about
the movie then obviously go watch it
first and then come back and watch this
because i'm gonna spoil pretty much the
whole thing so this movie ostensibly
follows
three uh young women
now one of these is cat who's played by
kiernan shipka who probably best known
for
being on mad men and then she was on
that sabrina show that was is that on
netflix i'm not really sure i haven't
seen it but she is on that uh so she's
in this uh lucy boynton
who plays a character named rose
she was also in i am the pretty thing
she played uh polly parsons
and then you have emma roberts uh
playing a character named joan
now these three uh young women's
storylines seem to be intersecting now
the one that we're
seeing kind of first
is uh the one between uh with cat and
rose
now these two young women are students
at a remote catholic boarding school
supposed to be upper upstate new york
although it's actually it was shot in
ottawa
so it's very very snowy very bleak very
isolated a nice little touch the
boarding school that they go to is
called the bramford which uh horror fans
will remember is the name of the
building where all the action took place
in rosemary's baby so you know uh you
know there's lots of little easter eggs
like that too i think there actually
might be another
sort of slight offhand reference to
rosemary's baby in there later on i'm
not entirely sure about that but i'll
kind of get into that in a minute
so cat is a freshman and rose is i'm
guess like an upperclassman like a
senior or something like that uh this is
set in february like i've seen some
reviews it's really weird because like i
read some reviews of it that seem like
they're really in depth but they get
like really
they get really easy [ __ ] wrong like a
couple reviews and i saw this said it
was set around christmas time it was
like christmas break it's clearly not uh
it's set in february like the end of
february so it's the end of winter the
winter semester and they're you know the
the students are taking a week off uh
you know for
whatever so and then the spring semester
will start afterward because it's very
very clearly there's a calendar
that cap marks off and it's you know the
end of february and the movie was called
february like when it started so that
should just clue you in right there
so these two uh young women it's the end
of february there's going to be a week's
vacation um there's kind of like a
little talent show type
thing that cat's going to be playing
piano and singing at
um but then everybody's parents are
gonna are supposed to come and pick up
the students and take them home for a
week
for their little vacation their winter
vacation
now uh for two very different reasons
uh neither cats nor rose's parents show
up to pick them up
now at first you're not entirely sure
why cat's parents don't show up now she
has had pretty much the first scene of
the movie is her having a nightmare
uh of her parents presumably
dying in a car crash or that's what
you're led to believe anyway
so she seems to believe this is true so
when her parents don't actually show up
to pick her up when they're supposed to
and when she's made it several attempts
to call them and the headmaster makes
attempts to call them and can't get you
know any can't get anybody they can't
get in touch with them she starts to
believe that they are dead
now rose uh her thing is that she has
been uh sneaking out with her boyfriend
so she's more like the rebellious chick
type
and she suspects that she might be
pregnant
and she wants a few more days to kind of
figure out what she's going to do like
before she sees her parents so she
actually presumably lied to her parents
about when the vacation started so they
wouldn't be there to pick her up
so these two girls uh are kind of left
at the school the headmaster leaves
it's a catholic school so they also have
kind of like the head priest guy or
whatever his name is father brian i
think and basically they're just kind of
like okay well we can't get hold of
either one of your parents so you're
just gonna have to stay here for a few
days until your parents show up the
headmaster's leaving the head priest is
leaving but there are these two
uh nuns these two women who live at the
school presumably and they're like okay
well they'll be here and uh they ask
rose the older student to look after cat
the younger one now pretty shortly after
this happens because rose is just kind
of like yeah no i'm not like babysitting
this kid who it's like i don't even know
i don't even know her and also she's a
little bit weird so she's basically like
you know just don't touch my [ __ ] stay
out of my room um you know i'm not
babysitting you and so she just like
sneaks out to see her boyfriend again
like to tell him about being pregnant or
whatever
now
over the course of the story cat's
behavior starts getting weirder and
weirder
as i said for a long time you're not
actually sure if her parents are really
dead or if there's something else going
on
um but she starts
just acting real creepy like she kind of
acts creepy even from the beginning
because there's this really strange uh
discussion with
uh the headmaster or actually no it's
with father brian
at the beginning and she's kind of
asking him why he's not coming to her
piano recital and he's like oh i have to
go to albany and all this other stuff
and she's just acting really strange you
know what i mean and like the stuff she
says is really strange
so she's kind of not right like from the
very very beginning but as the movie
goes on
her behavior starts getting weirder and
weirder like she starts looking like
she's really ill you know she comes to
the table at one point and pretty much
barfs all over the table when they ask
her to say grace
she's answering the phone and like
talking she seems to be like talking to
somebody and rose even uh hears voices
coming through the
the radiator
and goes down to the basement and finds
her
pretty much like prostrating herself in
front of the boiler like in the basement
like doing this really creepy like kind
of thing like that and she's like what
the [ __ ] is up with this chick so they
have all these really kind of weird
discussions
now all while all that's going on we're
also intercutting with another
story that you're actually not sure
until the end how it relates to the main
story i guess
and this story is following um another
young girl whose name is presumably joan
and she gets off the bus like at this
bus station
and you can tell she's had this weird
like flashbacks
uh of a cop like you know pointing a gun
at her
and uh there's also a quick flashback of
her
looks like she's strangling somebody
maybe
so she's in the bathroom of this bus
station and she's pulling like a you
know a medical bracelet like off arm so
you're presuming that she has escaped
from a mental hospital and that is
indeed uh what has happened
so she's at this bus station
and is looking for a place to go and
this good samaritan couple
uh this couple named bill and linda
he actually uh he's very very religious
and he feels bad for her because she's
sitting out waiting for somebody like
this but it's freezing cold outside and
she just has a really light coat on and
so he feels bad and he's like well you
know where are you going we'll give you
a ride
and it comes to pass that they are
actually going to bramford
now the first time you watch this movie
the first time i watched this movie
i thought oh these are cat's parents and
they're on the way to the school
uh to pick her up and they're running
late maybe they're running late because
they picked this girl up or something
like that you know there's little clues
to the things like there's some uh like
a bouquet of flowers in the back seat
which i thought oh well they're going to
you know they see their daughter's
recital and they're bringing her flowers
for the recital or whatever and or to
apologize for being late or whatever
whatever it is and there's even like a
branford bumper sticker on the back so
obviously they have
you know they they have a daughter that
goes to that school
so
that's and i think that that is what the
movie wants you to think
however that is uh actually not what's
going on
um but i like that the movie kind of
like misdirects you to that way
so we're following that story too and
like i said original like when you first
see the movie you're not really sure how
joan's story
relates to that the little bitty clues
start to come like you know just a
little bit and this is a movie again
that you really really have to pay
attention to every single little detail
because when you watch it again after
knowing what the twist is like i hate
calling it a twist that sounds so m
night shyamalan but it's
it's a kind of a twist i guess but
the i guess revelation would be a better
word so essentially if you know the
revelation you can go back and watch
like the first two thirds of the movie
and there's all kind of little clues in
there about what's really going on but
if you don't know then you don't really
so i like that it's very very subtle but
it is actually there
so meanwhile back at bramford school cat
is getting pretty damn crazy and it
comes to pass
that she basically believes that she is
possessed by the devil like i said it
kind of it it follows their narratives
like sort of chronologically kind of
but it does cut back and forth between
them so you're not entirely sure like
what the timeline is right
but she starts seeing i mean she like
the phone rings and the hallway and she
picks it up and a demonic voice is you
know telling her things and she calls it
daddy and stuff and uh she starts seeing
it uh essentially what it looks it kind
of looks like i i really like the
decision of showing the devil at least
as she's perceiving it it's basically
just kind of like a fuzzy shadow
just in the corner like or standing
behind somebody or something like that
if you can't see its face it's just this
black fuzzy thing with like big horns
and it kind of looks like krampus
actually some people said it looked like
the bunny from donnie darko like frank
uh which it kind of does too but like i
said it's just
it looks more like krampus to me
honestly it looks kind of fuzzy with
like big horns but you never see its
face you never see it's always just like
this kind of blurry shadow that she sees
in the background
so it comes to pass that this uh that
the devil that has possessed her
essentially is telling her to
kill everybody at the school the movie
really the theme of the whole movie the
whole point of cat's character is
loneliness is her you know isolation
and even though she's at a school with
all these other girls you can tell even
at the beginning and like i said so much
of this is unspoken a lot of it is
implication a lot of it is in her in the
actresses facial expressions
uh so it's very very subtle but it
actually is there if you look into it
and there's there's hints that a lot of
stuff that was maybe going on
in her background or in her history and
none of it's really overt
but
you can kind of come up with a lot of
different interpretations of maybe
why
she became possessed by the devil if she
is indeed possessed by the devil because
there's kind of a controversy
about whether cat
is actually possessed as in you know the
devil is actually really at the school
and it took advantage of her
vulnerability of her loneliness uh and
her lack of
her lack of ability to connect with
anyone else uh her fear of abandonment
that's kind of a big thing too did it
just take advantage of that or is she
just severely mentally ill and that's
how her mental illness is manifesting
itself by making her believe that she's
possessed by the devil i lean more
toward the latter
but you could totally read it either way
most people that think that she is
actually possessed they point out that
at the very beginning of the movie
she has what appears to be a premonition
that her parents are dead uh that they
died in a car crash on the way to get
her
now
the thing about it though is that one
they leave it i don't i don't know if
i'd say they leave it ambiguous but it
is implied that her parents did die they
never say it out right
but there is a scene where
uh you know mr gordon the headmaster he
actually shows up at one point later on
with a cop
and they're kind of like talking about
and the nuns like know some information
and they tell it to rose the other girl
but they don't tell cat
so i'm assuming that the news was that
her parents are indeed dead because they
never do show up so it is like
supernatural maybe that she had a
premonition that her parents were dead
because that happened at the very
beginning of the movie but
that happening at the very beginning in
the movie
that doesn't necessarily mean that's
what it happened you know what i mean so
i kind of feel like yeah the devil might
have told her hey your parents are dead
uh you have nobody because one of the
themes of the movie too is that
you know with whether it was for
knowledge or not of knowing that her
parents are dead and they're never
coming for her
uh leaving her alone and abandoned and
then there's all this kind of stuff
where she's left alone at the school
with rose rose is just kind of like yeah
i'm not babysitting you get the [ __ ] out
of my room and she just doesn't want to
deal with her so there's rejection right
there uh you know and there's one scene
where
when rose even later on like comes back
and it's like hey you okay she's like oh
you had your chance like you had your
chance to be my friend like to connect
with me and you didn't so it's too late
for you now
there's also scenes earlier where she's
talking to
you know father brian and it seems upset
that he's going to albany and he's not
going to be there for her
recital you know there's a scene with mr
gordon the headmaster like after you
know it's determined that her parents
are late or not showing up and he says
something kind of jokingly oh well you
can't live here um and then later on
like when she's talking on the phone
like to the devil presumably um she
calls it mr gordon a few times like mr
gordon says i can live here so
cat's character this is actually a very
tragic i mean the [ __ ] she does is like
not forgivable like later on because she
gets real stabby and murdery later
but
it's very sad because she was clearly
very mentally ill
and even though she went to a school
with a bunch of other girls couldn't
really connect with anybody so she was
very isolated and this sort of inciting
incidence perhaps incident perhaps of
her parents dying and leaving her
completely alone you know either made
her vulnerable to a psychotic break in
which she perceived that she was
possessed by the devil or if you want to
read a more supernatural you know more
exorcisty type of thing uh she actually
was possessed by the devil the devil
just took advantage of her vulnerability
during that time period
because there is a scene where and this
is perhaps where the idea was put into
her head
or there might be another reading to it
too where rose tells her oh the two nuns
that were left at the school like to
take care of them oh it was rumored that
they were satanists that they found them
one time like down in the boiler room
and their heads were shaved they don't
have any hair on their bodies and all
this other kind of stuff so i don't
really know you could read it
in the way that rose telling her that
story
put the idea into her head that you know
there's satanism going on and it's and
that's just how her
you know mental illness or her mental
breakdown manifested itself or you could
argue uh that the nuns were actually
satanists so satan was just kind of like
hanging around this building
and uh you know and they saw this vault
he saw this vulnerable little girl then
decided he was going to possess her or
take advantage or whatever the
interesting thing about this story
uh and i haven't even got into the whole
like revelation about joe and i'll get
into that in a minute
but the interesting thing about this
story is that
you could call it an exorcism movie uh
because there is kind of like a little
minor exorcism yes it is she is
supposedly possessed she does like the
contortion and the throwing up and
everything very very subtle very
downplayed it's not like it's not like
one of those movies where like you know
your standard exorcism movie where she
does all this like crazy [ __ ] it's
almost kind of like a subversion of that
because the interesting thing about it
is that if she is indeed possessed by
the devil or perceives that she is
possessed by the devil
she doesn't want the devil to leave she
sees the the devil as
her only friend
uh or perhaps as a father figure because
there's kind of an underlying thing of
that there's also kind of an underlying
and maybe um maybe i'm just seeing this
and this isn't in there but i thought
that there was also kind of an
underlying
slight subtle implication of maybe
sexual abuse maybe not coming from her
dad but maybe she does seem to have like
some weird i hate to use the phrase
daddy issues but she does seem to have
like some serious daddy issues so i
don't they never show her father in her
premonition of the car crash
she's walking beside
a man who you presume is her father who
has a black coat on and then you see
like the wrecked car with uh with blood
and stuff and she says you know mom like
as in her mom was in the car but she
says to dad that's like oh do you came
early she says um there's also a scene
which is like a flashback scene which is
actually jones flashback of father brian
kind of like leaning over here over her
and you find out that later that that
was like an exorcism but there was also
kind of an implication because you know
catholic priests
they they have a certain
reputation
you know what i'm saying justified or
not i'm just saying there's a there's a
reputation that they have and so that
scene in particular that being a
flashback
might have been implying something else
so
the whole storyline with joan what you
find out with joan
as i mentioned earlier in joan's
storyline obviously she's escaped from a
mental hospital she's trying to go back
to
bramford although she doesn't say that
she's actually says she's going to the
next town or the town before that
so this couple that picks her up who at
first you think are cat's parents
but you find out over the course of the
story as joan's story goes on you find
out that these are actually rose's
parents
and that rose is dead and that this is
actually nine years later so the whole
stuff that you thought was going on in
the same timeline that's not going on
the same timeline the whole thing with
rose and cat was nine years ago the
stuff with joan and rose's parents is
present day
so the they're actually going to
bramford because that's where rose was
murdered and they're putting flowers on
her grave which is something that they
do every year
now it turns out that joan
is not her real name joan is actually uh
the woman that she killed to escape from
the mental hospital and stole her id so
that's why that's the name she's going
by
joan is actually cat nine years later
and you find out that she was put in the
asylum because obviously she killed the
nuns and she killed
uh rose in a really horrible way cut off
their heads and took their heads down to
the boiler room as an offering to the
demon so uh because this happened she
was actually taken to a mental hospital
father brian came and did an exorcism on
her
but the exorcism which like i said was
just kind of like a minor like hey get
out or whatever but cat
doesn't want the demon to leave like she
and the exorcism she looks over and she
sees the devil over there like the
shadow and she says don't go that was
her only friend that was her father
figure
so he also abandoned her in the end
so she gets sent to a mental hospital
she's in there for nine years
and then she escapes with the hopes of
going back to the brantford and making
another offering of heads uh to the
devil in in the hopes that he will come
back
so that's kind of what she did now some
people have were confused
that
you know oh when when joan slash cap
broke out of the mental health she was
actually
going to
specifically like hunt rose's parents
like to kill them that is not the case
it was a total coincidence because
there's a whole discussion
after um
bill and linda rose's parents like pick
joan up and they take you know they they
get her a hotel room and stuff like that
and there's a whole discussion between
bill and joan
where it's mostly bill talking joan
doesn't hardly say anything but bill is
discussing he's like well i you know
he's very religious so he says well i
see god in all these coincidences and
the fact that i saw you on the bus bench
and you remind me of my daughter who was
rose and i believe we should you know
help people and i don't believe in
coincidences the irony of the fact is
that you know he thought he sees god in
the coincidences but you could argue
that satan was in the coincidences
because honestly like joan when she
finds out that these are rose's parents
these are the parents of the girl she
killed nine years ago
um she just almost can't believe her
luck she's like in the bathroom but she
like laughs
you know what i mean like oh my god i
can't believe that happened this must be
meant to be i think that was what the
implication was that she thought that
was satan
saying to her hey you know i brought you
these like kill them and bring them and
all come back and so she thought that's
what she was supposed to do it was meant
to be
so she ends up
killing the parents
and take cutting their heads off and
taken the heads back to the bramford
which because of the tragedy has now
been closed and abandoned
and uh the sad thing about it is that
she takes these heads
down to the boiler where she contacted
the devil before and puts them there but
the boiler is cold the devil is gone
and so the very last scene of the movie
is jones lash cat grown-up cat
and she's just in this you know on this
road with all this snow in the middle of
nowhere there's nowhere else around
and she just like screams and cries
because either because i guess it could
be both things either because she
realizes now she's completely alone the
devil's not going to come back
or she realizes that she just killed two
people for nothing like it was just like
a sacrifice and she did it on her own
she wasn't even possessed so she didn't
have that excuse you know it was all it
was all for nothing she just murdered
them for nothing so
honestly like the more
you watch this movie like the more
little details and layers and [ __ ] like
that you find it about and it's just i
liked it so much better i mean i liked
it the first time and i you know when i
got it the first time i got the twist
that joan is supposed to be cat yes it's
a different actress
and i kind of feel like people bitched a
lot about that too like they felt like
oh that was a cheat because those two
actresses don't look anything alike
but i think you'll find if you put
pictures of them next to each other they
actually do look quite a bit alike so
it's not crazy to think that cat was you
know she's put into mental asylum and
obviously she looks kind of different
when she comes out it's been nine years
and maybe she hasn't been you know
treated all that well or she's had like
some [ __ ] going on so it's not crazy to
think that
yeah and honestly they they actually did
the two actresses that played the two
parts because a lot of people complain
too it's like oh they look like they're
the same age but in real life those
actresses were actually almost exactly
nine years apart which i'm pretty sure
they did on purpose so
it's totally plausible but i mean
obviously if if they'd used the same
actress or that you'd used actresses
that looked even more alike
then you wouldn't have had that
misdirection
aspect to it you would have thought you
know you would have figured it out
immediately and i think it's better to
not figure out immediately and i i like
movies like this that
don't really like hold your hand you
know like i said it's going on two
different timelines but you don't really
realize that until like the third act
and i think that
is actually like really really cool i
mean honestly i
when i figured it out i figured it out
in the scene with the restaurant with
bill and joan and he is like oh here's
my daughter she died he didn't say she
was murdered he just said she died nine
years ago
and he says something to joan like oh
you she'd be your age now so that's
another clue and shows the picture and
it's rose and i was just kind of like oh
my god that's gotta be cat then like
nine years later but it's so it took me
like that long to figure it out uh but i
did actually figure out but the but
knowing that it's actually great to go
back and watch it again because there's
just so much like subtle little imagery
and it's one of those ones too where um
there's actually like a lot of little
scenes of like the devil like he's kind
of like reflected very vaguely like in
the you know in the tiles in the
bathroom so it's all very very subtle
the cinematography on this gorgeous like
i said if you really liked um i am the
pretty thing i probably mentioned this
when i talked about that movie that
there's just some there's this real
creeping like unease
about the way the shots are framed i
believe this is the same uh
cinematographer that did both of these
if please correct me if i'm wrong
but um the the way that the the movies
are framed
where you're never really sure like
there's you know there's these kind of
in i am the pretty thing there was like
these white walls and then like this
doorway into another was just like black
you know what i mean so you were always
kind of expecting things to like kind of
be creeping around in the corners and so
this kind of has that similar kind of
thing where it's just like this some of
these wide shots and everything's like
very stark and bleak and isolated and
you're never really sure
where like where something might be
lurking or what might be happening
around the corner so so this is another
movie that while not it's not scary
scary there's not like big jump scares
or anything like that
but it's definitely like really
unsettling
and the implications of it really stick
with you because as i mentioned this is
almost like an inversion of an exorcism
movie an exorcism movie being you know
someone usually a young woman is invaded
by a demon and it takes their agency
away whereas this one is a girl who is
inviting the demon in and doesn't want
it to leave and is willing to you know
is willing to commit murder and
beheading uh to
get the demon to stay because she's so
desperate
for a friend or for someone who will
uh who will be with her forever
and so in that way
you know as horrifying as what she does
is
you kind of feel bad for her because
she's just so broken you know and she
just has this like i said this this
sense of like loss and abandonment that
no one will
will stay with her nobody loves her and
nobody needs her and the fact that she
was that open to you know doing anything
just
just to have this devil inside of her
that that gave her
i don't know just just this friendship
or love that she never she felt like she
never had so
in a way i can't really think of another
exorcism type movie where
somebody wanted the demon you know what
i mean where it wasn't an invasion it
was actually what well i guess you could
say the witch was kind of like that and
there was actually a movie it was kind
of more of a horror comedy called ava's
possessions was it a comedy yeah i guess
it was more of like a horror comedy and
even the main character didn't want the
demon but there was another
if you haven't seen ava's possessions
it's actually about
people who were possessed by demons and
then there's like a um there's like a
support group for people that used to be
like so it's kind of funny but it's it's
really good actually if you haven't seen
it i think it came out in 2016 2017
something like that uh but there was
another it wasn't the main character but
there was another girl in the support
group who was trying to get the demon
back because she really she really liked
him so but other than that i can't
really think of
any other exorcism possession type movie
that really has that really explores
this sort of gray area of
you know what if
somebody was just so
lost and broken and isolated and alone
that they were completely willing to
have this demon
come in there because it was the only
thing that loved them um and like i said
it's kind of like a daddy kind of figure
too because i definitely feel like
there's a lot of father figure type
stuff going on in this um that like i
said nothing's overt this is a very very
subtle very restrained type of movie
like i said some people might say boring
because like oh there's nothing going on
this has more going on than i am the
pretty thing for sure especially in the
third act because like i said it gets
pretty gnarly like there's
stabbings and beheadings and
crazy [ __ ] like that going on but it's
kind of the same type of thing like i
said it's very deliberately paced um you
know and you really have to pay
attention to little bitty details to get
the story because it's not
you know it there's not a lot of
dialogue that will tell you what the
story is everything's kind of like
between
the lines you know what i mean so it's
that kind of thing and i love movies
like that i know some people don't and
i'm not [ __ ] on you if you don't uh
i'm just saying obviously this is it's
an a24 movie that's uh who distributed
it and those are not everyone's cup of
tea i get that but uh this one
honestly i
watching this one a second time i think
i would i the first time i watched this
one and i am the pretty thing i think i
slightly prefer to have the pretty thing
because i really liked uh the creepy
like the ghost story type thing and i
liked like the novelist i like that uh
that aspect but watching them a second
time i think i might slightly prefer
this one even though it does have some
tropes of
exorcism possession movies but it's
doing something interesting with it and
honestly i'm kind of of the opinion
and i'm not saying that like the other
interpretation is wrong i'm of the
opinion that there is no devil that
she's just that that's how
her mental breakdown is manifesting
itself so i don't think there's actually
a demon wandering around at the bramford
that the nuns like you know summoned or
whatever i think that that's
that she had the idea put into her head
because of you know the story that rose
told and just all these
things of her feeling like isolated from
everybody her parents dying and so i
think that's just how it manifested
itself so she started acting as though
acting like a possessed person would act
um i think but you could totally read it
the other way that the devil is real and
just took her over because she was
vulnerable um you know it works either
way which i think is like really great
and that's why i really like these
sort of like already ambiguous films
like this because there are just
multiple multiple interpretations and uh
you know i really like that
so if you have not seen this movie
obviously you should have stopped
watching by now because i just spoiled
pretty much the whole [ __ ] thing but
if you still want to watch it after all
that i think it might be on netflix in
the uk i don't think it's on netflix
here anymore i think i am the pretty
thing might still be um i actually
rented it on amazon prime for 3.99 i
think you can also rent it on youtube
for 3.99 and it's totally worth it if
you really like those creepy
atmospheric a24 indie art house type
movies um and you really like stuff that
you need to watch over and over again
because of all these little clues and
subtle hints and everything like that
then this will totally be right up your
alley so if you've seen it
let me know what you thought about it in
the comments if you have a different
interpretation to me i'd be really
interested to hear what it is and
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye